- Jamaislelelelelelelelelelelell
sur l'immunisation tranche
en faveur d'une troisième dose
de vaccin pour tous les adultes,
pa
Dr HOWARD NJOO, admin. chef adj.
de la santé publique du Canada
- Je pense que c'est le bon
moment maintenant, avant
le monde rentre à l'intérieur,
de lancer, comme on dit,
un programme de vaccination.
- Le Comité recommande fortement
priorité pour la troisième dose.
Dre CAROLINE QUACH, rererere,
microbiologiste-infectiologue
- Parce que c'est dans
voir le plus d'émoussement
avec l'avancéelelelele temps.
- Seront ensuite priorisés
les immunosupprimés,
ligne du secteur de la santé,
les Premières Nations et Inuits,
adulte. Il faudra néanmoins
patienter au moins six m
entre les 2e et la 3e doses.
- Je suis pas scueueueueue.
Si on dit de le faire,
on doit le faire. b b b b b b bs
ont fait la troisième dose
ou non, ça dépend
de plusieurs facteurs;
je suis pas IFIFIFIFIFIFIFIFIFIn
hygiéniste en chef du N.-B.
- La semaine prochaine,
nous étendrons...
- Le Nlelelelelelelelelelelelels
que Québec promet des lignes
directrices sous peu.
- J'espère bien être capable
de vous anébébébébébébébébébébé.
- Si la troisième dose promet
de contrecarrer l'avancée
du variant Delta, qui représente
pluseneneneneneneneneneneneneneé
contre le variant Omicron
reste à démontrer.
Dr ALEX CARIGNAN, microbiol.
- Pour l'instant, on n'a pas
de donnée sur l'efficacité
vaccinale face au variant
Omicron, mais c'est
une idée intéressante d'avoir
des taux d'anticorps plus
pour faire face à ce variant-là.
JEAN-YVES DUCLOS,
- Encore une fois, je répète,
si vous êtes admi
faites-vous donner votre dose
de rappel rapidement.
l'achat de 1,5 million
de comprimés cOVOVOVOVOVOVID-19
des fabricants Merck et Pfizer.
Ces traitements par voie orale
Santé Canada les aura approuvés.
Ici Jean-Philippe Hughes,
Radio-Canada, Montréal.